aaron rodgers has not been with the
packers for 20 years but almost he was a
first round pick in 2005 sat for three
years became the starter and now the
question is how are they going to work
through this awkwardness between him and
jordan love mike silver of nfl media and
fellow cow graduate reported yesterday
that aaron rodgers and the packers were
talking about some sort of restructuring
which presumably was some sort of
extension or raise or whatever there's a
report today from espn.com that the
packers have paid aaron rodgers his 6.8
million dollar roster bonus so there
goes that money which could have been
included in a signing bonus and made
part of a restructuring that would have
kept the cap number low for aaron
rodgers this year
doesn't mean they can't continue to work
on a new contract but to the extent the
goal was to lower his cap number 6.8
million opportunities to do so went out
the window today shireen
yeah and if people don't understand that
mike that would have spread out the
bonus over the next two years so in 2022
2023
the dead money if they chose to move on
from aaron rodgers would have increased
at this point it doesn't increase and so
they can more easily move on by move on
i mean trade aaron rodgers if that's
what they choose to do after this year
yes you're right they could choose to
restructure renegotiate add-on years
onto this contract doesn't mean they
won't but i do think this is significant
mike that they decided to to pay this
roster bonus as it was yeah instead of
making it uh
spread out over the length of the
contract so to me it is significant that
they did this i don't know how this ends
with aaron rodgers but i do know that
they didn't draft jordan love to sit on
the bench for four years and then move
on somewhere else or the fifth year
option and move on somewhere else i do
think jordan love is the quarterback of
the future for the packers it's just a
matter of win at this point mike
yeah look the bottom line is aaron
rodgers played extremely well last year
after the kick to the butt that came
from the selection of jordan love the
packers have the opportunity to treat
aaron rodgers as a year-to-year employee
he wants and i believe deserves greater
security than that a greater commitment
than that but from the packers
perspective that there i believe is a
sweet spot of saltiness
in which mark murphy the ceo of the team
likes to keep aaron rodgers having
pissed off sorry london but not overly
pissed off just agitated enough so he's
doing everything in his power to be the
guy that he was in 2020 but not so mad
that he clamors to get out and
i think that that this failed effort
apparently to renegotiate his contract
may be something that sticks in his
cross he's sharing if he's not willing
to ever be regarded potentially as the
bad guy in this and is so obsessed with
how he's viewed by packers fans and by
media and doesn't want to pick a fight
you never
you never have your full arsenal at your
disposal and i think mark murphy is
smart enough to know it and that's why
murphy was able to do what he did last
year in drafting love and possibly and
apparently do what he's doing this year
in not giving aaron rodgers the contract
he wanted
or the free agent said he wanted mike i
mean we know he wanted his running back
back and he got that right aaron jones
but they have signed no outside free
agents unless they did it today and i
missed it but i don't think they have i
know they hadn't as of yesterday and we
know he wanted them to improve this
roster and this roster does not look
improved so
uh i if i'm aaron rodgers i have big
questions about whether i can win a
super bowl with this roster as it is
i've had the best record the last couple
years 13 and three over the last two
years and it made it to the championship
game but haven't gotten beyond that so i
would question whether i can get this
team over the hump at some point you got
to have the talent around you as tom
brady found out this year he had the
talent around him to get it done mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports